et nous retrouvons maintenant notre
envoyé spécial elena volochine elena
bonjour vous vous trouvez à taganrog à
la frontière entre l'ukraine et la
russie vous êtes côté russe la réaction
de l'occident est elle à la mesure des
mots prononcés par vladimir poutine et
hier
c'est exactement toute la question c'est
de savoir est ce que l'occident prend la
mesure de ce qu'elle dit vladimir
poutine et il est ce qu'il sera prêt à
réagir parce que ce qu'a prononcé
vladimir poutine est fière comme
discours cela ressemblait à une leçon
d'histoire aux yeux de certains mais
cela ressemblait plus à un projet aux
yeux d'autres personnes qui observent
attentivement ce régime russe vladimir
poutine a effectivement dit que
l'ukraine telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui sur la carte et dans sa dent
dans sa gouvernance c'est une erreur de
l'histoire une erreur de l'union
soviétique une erreur plus précisément
de lénine qui a constitué des états au
sein de l'union soviétique on aurait
mieux fait de faire comme salines
voulait disait vladimir poutine de créer
d autonomie et la mine qui risquait de
tout faire exploser selon la lumière
poutine c'est la possibilité de sortir
de l'union soviétique autrement dit la
dîmière poutine ce qu'il voit c'est
effectivement un empire maintenant ce
n'est pas juste une idée quand on voit
ce qui se passe sur le terrain quand on
voit aussi qu'il a proféré des menaces
directes à l'égard de l'ukraine vous
voulez la décommunisation vous allez
voir à quoi ressemble la décolonisation
pour l'ukraine c'était une menace qu'il
a prononcé hier et lorsqu'on voit comme
disait guy l'hiver l'instant les temps
effectivement d'après ces vidéos qu'on
ne peut pas authentifiée pour le moment
mais qui serait entré dans les
territoires séparatistes dans ce projet
les territoires séparatistes ne serait
qu'un détail puisque on voit aussi une
grande concentration de troupes dans la
région de belgorod avec kharkiv de
l'autre côté de la frontière ukrainienne
des sources paramilitaires en russie
envoie des signaux inquiétants disons
qu'il y aurait la possibilité
et l'éventualité envisager d'aller au
delà du nom basse tout ceci faisant
lorsque l'on parle de sanction côté
occidental alors que vladimir poutine a
dit hier que les sanctions ne lui
faisait absolument pas peur parce que de
toute façon quoi qu'ils fassent
l'occident aurait adopté des sanctions
contre la russie et qu'il voit un
occident et en notant commune direct
menace ce qu'il a dit hier explique
cette propagande qu'on entend depuis des
années depuis le début du conflit en
2014 de génocide de nazis il a explicité
clairement hier ce qu'il entendait par
là et vladimir poutine donc il ya cette
vision complètement un père alliés
impérialistes au jour d'aujourd'hui qui
est potentiellement prêt à aller à
l'action militaire quelle réponse
va-t-il rencontré en face de lui c'est
ce qu'on va voir dans les prochains
heures avec les réunions à tout niveau
diplomatique occidentale qui vont se
tenir elena volochine depuis 7h
frontière entre russie et l'ukraine
merci